[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
Paris qui comme on sait aime à être
étonné va faire la connaissance
d'inquiétant coléoptère ce sont les
dernières créations d'un jeune peintre
célèbre passer à la sculpture Bernard
Buffet car c'est de lui qu'il s'agit est
venu avec sa femme Annabelle installer
son Muséum autrement dit sa collection
d'insectes de 2 m de haut fruit de 8
mois de travail et résultat d'une
vieille passion pour l'histoire
naturelle l'occasion ne manquera pas de
rêver devant ces créatures faites de
files de fer de câbl électrique de
plâtre de TRG métallique et de bande
Velpo mais dont la moindre vaut ses 6
millions de francs ancien bien
[Musique]
entendu à 74 ans la Tour Effel peut
aujourd'hui espérer être classé monument
historique en même temps du reste qu'une
deventure du boulevard de la Madeleine d
à l'architecte my Stevens et l'hôtel
particulier du verrier René
[Musique]
Lalic le principe en a été admis par la
commission supérieure des monuments
historiques soucieuse de nous conserver
intacte des monuments de notre époque
non sans éclectisme puisqueavec la
synagogue de la rue pavé un garage de la
rue de pontiieux serait également élevé
à la dignité de monuments historique un
garage voilà bien un de ces monuments de
notre temps celui-là est en l'œuvre des
frères
P mais ne devrait-on pas faire un pas de
plus et penser aussi à sauver un des
derniers becs de
gaz ne devrait-on pas aussi classer un
de ces bistr à grille qui finiront par
disparaître
[Musique]
si l'on a fait un sort au moulin de la
galette qui vit passer tant de meunier
et tant de Mimi Pinon ne devrait-on pas
en faire un à cette édicule de
Saint-Germain des pré qui fut si
intimement mêlé à la vie littéraire
d'après-gerre et faute d'avoir été
classé que deviendra cet éternel sauvé
des
EAU même dans les grands magasins
l'arrivée à Paris du groupe des Beatles
a déclenché un rush on sait qu'en dehors
de leur style vocal les Beatles ont mis
l'accent sur l'originalité de leur
coiffure et la perruque Beatles fait en
ce moment les beau jours d'une foule de
copains qui ont de l'enthousiasme à
revendre celle-là c'est du
[Musique]
vrai il paraît qu'une telle perruque va
à tout le monde ilut faut pas croire
toutefois qu'elle donne de la voix
dispense du talent et assure la
célébrité pas mal d'entre nous
passeraient même ainsi coiffé pour de
doufolat mais on leur promet en tout cas
un succès
[Musique]
ébourifant dans la nuit des temps et
dans la nuit tout court des nonsintilles
qui évoque des silhouettes ou des
visages mais Max Linder AE seulement le
nom d'un cinéma on le retrouve
aujourd'hui après un oubli de 40 ans
grâce à l'amour de sa fille MAE Linder
de nouvelles foules viennent remplacer
les foules d'avant l'autre guerre pour
voir ce personnage qui fut aux origines
du cinéma le premier grand comique et la
première grande vedette le cinéma avait
10 ans lorsqu'il débuta mais rapidement
son image emplit les salles et couvrit
les murs de Paris c'eston qu'il fut à
son époque la première vedette
internationale c'eston qu'il fut de 1905
à 1925 l'auteur et l'acteur de plus de
600 films et qu'il toucha des cachets
supérieurs à ceux de l Tor et qu'quit un
public plus grand que celui de Brigitte
bardau que reste-t-il de cette vie
fulgurante sa villa de la vararen
toujours debout mais tombé au rang de
Château de Belle au bois
dormant les vieux studios de Vincen qui
furent le départ de gigantesques
installations de Hollywood l'hôtel où il
se suicida un jour de 1925 on l'a oublié
pendant 40 ans pourtant quelle place fut
la sienne écoutons Marcel
si je devais écrire pour un dictionnaire
académique une définition de Max Linder
je dirais célèbre comique français qui
par ses inventions ses trouvailles ses
gages son génie a été non seulement le
précurseur mais l'inventeur du comic
américain il laissait un disciple génial
char Chaplin qui a dit sans Max Linder
je n'aurais jamais fait de cinéma je
salue en lui mon professeur et mon
maître et il faut rendreâ grce à Mae
Linder la fille du grand disparu qui
après des années de recherch et de
patience a su nous réapprendre le nom de
ce père qu'elle n'a pas connu et dont le
visage nous redevient vivant comme celui
d'un ami
retrouvé cette semaine vous allez voir
le 7e épisode de soyez ma femme vous
n'avez pas oublié que Max est fiancé
avec la ravissante esmeréraldine il se
rend chez un très grand couturier pour
lui offrir la robe de ses rêves mais
comme toujours de nombreuses aventures
[Musique]
l'attendent
le Grand Prix d'Amérique a fait vivre la
France entière dans la fièvre durant les
quelques minutes de la course 5
milliards de Paris il est vrai justifier
cette effervescence dans les tribunes et
sur la plouse de Vincen 45000 spectateur
vociférant le gagnant ce ne sera pas
celui-là Patara le numéro 14 va être
victime d'un drame ce trotteur
magnifique va disparaître juste avant la
dernière ligne droite le sulk heurtera
un piquet de la corde et simonard le
driver sera proocheter au
sol bien malin celui qui avait pensé au
vainqueur vous le voyez qui déboule en
tête c'est le 13 le cheval
italoaméricain Nike Hanover il apporte
une fortune sous ses sabots à ceux qui
ont eu le flire de lui faire
confiance
13 9 12 un tiercé que les gagnants ne
sont pas prêts
[Musique]
d'oublier cette jeune femme de 32 ans
crissa pellcier va refaire toute seule à
bord d'un tout petit avion de 180
chevaux la ligne héroïque de Jean merm
parti dis soir en 40 he de vol elle veut
atteindre rio janeiro deux femmes
seulement avant elle ont réalisé cette
exploit la Néerlandaise John bon en 1931
et maris Bastier en 1935 depuis ni homme
ni femme personne n'a renouvelé cette
performance voici son plan de vol en
tout 10000 km dont plus de 3000 km
au-udessus de l'Atlantique même à
l'époque des cosmonautes c'est encore un
exploit c'est au Canada que se déroule
cette scène mais n'allz surtout pas
croire que les Canadiens ont la boujotte
et qu'ils déplacent comme cela leur
petit chalet par goût des voyages pas du
tout c'est pour aller à la pêche que les
habitants du village canadien français
de Saint-Anne de la Pérade effectuent ce
déménagement ils aiment la pêche mais la
pêche dans le confort alors comme les
poissons ne viennent pas tout seul chez
eux dans leur appartement pour mordre à
l'hameçon Cassel tienne petit poisson
c'est la maison qui va jusqu'à vous et
qui s'installe sur le lac
[Musique]
gelé et voilà le tour est joué on peut
comme cela pêcher du poisson frais tout
en fumant sa pipe au coin du feu ou en
continuant de vivre comme chez
[Musique]
soi
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]